walk him to this video playing as I walk
out this Montenegro right he stopped
playing from Montenegro usually this is
love Kochi Chuck usually yeah his is a
Swedish player he doesn't have Swedish
he doesn't come from Sweden originally
but he's playing for Sweden for ages so
this flag gets a bit irritating maybe is
playing a tournament in Montenegro okay
so we have the h3 keys in Yemen is
played with Knight to d7 um now you can
play that I wonder maybe he's some
intending to go for a bank Oh gambit c5
d 5b v but maybe maybe this is an idea
protecting me for this is a move that
fits in a5 setups in 5 d5 but also fits
Andrew c5 I'm not so sure about c6 b5
which is also an idea maybe he's playing
that now no yeah I thought in the Benoni
m92 is a pretty decent idea ok it's it's
it's a playable position for black of
course I'm not saying like it's terrible
shape of 92 looks like a viable approach
now we can't play b5 but it's just one
of those huh this is interesting
okay let's set up the g4 match as long
as I am able to h5 this is one of the
one of the interesting ways to play it
you can now try to take and play night
h7 but I have night f3 night edged up
with the idea to play Bishop f6 to g5 me
yep this is why I'm going here and no
night 95
yeah this looks like a very good
position for white I've got the H file
open already
and something like Queen d2 and Bishop
h6 later can can be very very dangerous
yeah I think you misjudged this
especially 90 f6 is really a rather
rather pointless move
so f3 just protect you four and then
Queen d2 maybe I can I could have
managed without the move but I think I
can afford it
yeah Bishop age six he's going Bishop
Bishop f6 but I can I can just retreat
here and prepare doubling on the edge
farm he still wants to play Bishop f6
mmm
and Bishop g5 the question should I play
g5 yeah it keeps it keeps it keeps an
advantage with the castles and doubling
on the edge from
yeah of course b5 I need to know I don't
take any poncey or something the age
trial is the the big thing here so now I
am I need I need the Queen's know how to
get this quickly Queen to h4 is not a
winning black Queen e1 h form maybe rook
edge to was stupid I should have played
rook H form rook edge for Queen edge to
the sir would be it would be very nice
stupid
okay let's spend a move on on proof
Lexus keep a - cupboard I don't want him
to take
just yeah maybe look edge from Queen
Queen edge too so I just lost time with
all that could have had this in a better
version I hope it's still winning
so Bishop g5 and said the winning I
don't know if it takes on g5 and takes
on c3 rook h8 check
yeah it doesn't mean he cannot cannot
take it queen g5 queen c3 rogachev it's
Janet yeah this is another possibility
of course check so I hope this keeps
things under control
well this was probably completely
unnecessary to get into this year yeah I
wonder what what what am I playing if he
just goes Bishop g7 or something maybe
Bishop h6 still yeah that's not spend so
much time this was my idea anyway
keeping it closed and I still have an
attack I mean it's it's probably so very
good for what
okay
Queen g5 28 hmm
be here I don't see when I don't see a
win
cannot calculate urban here she goes
Quincy five I don't know what I'm doing
I can I can check here but it's I'm not
sure that I'm winning
check factory whoo page seven know I
have this is Django black resigns well
what a game
whoo yeah I really allowed her too much
play here this this here I mean black
setup is quite questionable
strategically anyway but this is this is
just just asking for it here white why
this is basically winning strategically
but I just allowed far too much far too
much play here yeah g5 is probably okay
I want to prevent Bishop f6 g5 so up to
this point I'm pretty pretty satisfied
and this is from the already bit but a
bit imprecise maybe maybe this one to be
quicker if it if it goes similar to the
game just just for argument's sake then
I have this idea and this is just
quicker than the game
yeah the compass already I'm plus two
here this is this is terrible yeah well
in the game
I had this rook edge tool and the
computer still says white is winning but
it was it was simply was not not precise
check-check
yeah calm wants to play this as well
this is also the best news okay yeah
this is computer actually likes my plane
I'm surprised and now it wants to play
f4 with +99 is a lot I hope this is also
winning that is check and now look h7s
actually leading to a major I couldn't
calculate that and this is also might
okay so I played better than I then I
actually believed in the game I really
thought you would have have something
but the computer actually believes that
white is basically winning all long-stay
Rukh age for first instead of rook h2 to
here this would have been would have
been the better choice punishing him him
on the edge from the problem with this
kind of syllabus that black is rather
passive he I cannot really break with
that five and b5 is also hard to do and
h5 is some is a typical way to play to
get something to g5 Bishop f6 to g5 it
simply didn't work out in the game I
could always prevent that so this is why
this isn't a good idea it's a good
general concept but it's not working in
this concrete position yeah thanks for
watching